[Music]
consider the classic white t-shirt
annually we sell and buy two billion
t-shirts globally making it one of the
most common garments in the world but
how and where is the average t-shirt
made and what's its environmental impact
clothing items can vary a lot but a
typical t-shirt begins its life on a
farm in America China or India where
cotton seeds are sown irrigated and
grown for the fluffy bowls they produce
self-driving machines
carefully harvest these puffs an
industrial cotton gin mechanically
separates the fluffy bowls from the
seeds and the cotton lint is pressed
into 225 kilogram bales the cotton
plants require a huge quantity of water
and pesticides 2700 liters of water are
needed to produce the average t-shirt
enough to fill more than 30 bathtubs
meanwhile cotton uses more insecticides
and pesticides than any other crop in
the world these pollutants can be
carcinogenic harm the health of field
workers and damage surrounding
ecosystems some t-shirts are made of
organic cotton grown without pesticides
and insecticides but organic cotton
makes up less than 1% of the 22.7
million metric tons of cotton produced
worldwide once the cotton bales leave
the farm textile mills shipped them to a
spinning facility usually in China or
India where high-tech machines blend
card comb pull stretch and finally twist
the cotton into snowy ropes of yarn
called slivers then yarns are sent to
the mill where huge circular knitting
machines weave them into sheets of rough
grayish fabric treated with heat and
chemicals until they turn soft and white
here the fabric is dipped into
commercial bleaches and azo dyes which
make up the vivid coloring in about 70%
of textiles unfortunately some of these
contain cancer-causing cadmium lead
chromium and mercury other harmful
compounds and chemicals can cause
widespread contamination when released
as toxic waste water in rivers and
oceans technologies are now so advanced
in some countries that the entire
process of growing and producing fabric
barely touches a human hand but only up
until this point after the finished
cloth travels to factories often in
Bangladesh China India or Turkey human
labor is still required to stitch them
up into t-shirts intricate work that
machines just can't do this process has
its own problems Bangladesh for example
which has surpassed China as the world's
biggest exporter of cotton t-shirts
employs 4.5 million people in the
t-shirt industry but they typically face
poor conditions and low wages after
manufacture all those t-shirts travel by
ship train and truck to be sold in
high-income countries a process that
gives cotton an enormous carbon
footprint some countries produce their
own clothing domestically which cuts out
this polluting stage but generally
apparel production accounts for 10% of
global carbon emissions and it's
escalating cheaper garments and the
public's willingness to buy boosted
global production from 1994 to 2014 by
400 percent to around 80 billion
garments each year finally in a
consumers home the t-shirt goes through
one of the most resource intensive
phases of its lifetime in America for
instance the average household does
nearly 400 loads of laundry per year
each using about 40 gallons of water
washing machines and dryers both use
energy with dryers requiring 5 to 6
times more than washers
this dramatic shift in clothing
consumption over the last 20 years
driven by large corporations and the
trend of fast fashion has cost the
environment the health of farmers and
driven questionable human labour
practices it's also turned fashion into
the second largest polluter in the world
after oil but there are things we can do
consider shopping secondhand try to look
for textiles made from recycled or
organic fabrics wash clothes less and
line dry to save resources instead of
throwing them away at the end of their
life donate recycle or reuse them as
cleaning rags and finally you might ask
yourself how many t-shirts and articles
of clothing will you consume over your
lifetime and what will be their combined
impact on the world when we produce
ted-ed videos about the environment we
often think about the young people who
subscribe to this channel and how unfair
it is that you're inheriting
environmental problems that were
probably set into motion long before you
were born
the good news is that we see students
everywhere making moves to meet the
world's biggest challenges head-on for
example in Ted Ed's student voice
program sustainability has emerged as a
topic of choice in thousands of
presentations given by students
throughout the world you can watch their
talks on the ted-ed club's youtube
channel and you can learn more about the
program by visiting Edie dot ted.com
slash clubs as always thanks for
watching
[Music]